It's a hard life out here.
So a goal is to go out
trapping and get some fur.
And the animals out here
that are growing with the land
will make garments
that are meant to be on this land.
This is what I'm looking for right here.
I got a natural game trail.
The animals, they continue to use this
because the snow is so deep,
they take advantage of any sort of little
like natural trail that they make
and being on the border of this lake,
there's a lot of natural cubbies
for me to set some traps,
but I have to be able to find them.
So I'll take advantage
of the bank of this lake and this game
trail.
I honestly think I can take advantage
of this little spot because there's
a lot of these little alders standing up
and I can use that as a way to funnel
the animals to the front of the trap,
so I might make that little game trail.
You know, I got to walk up to the trap,
so using snowshoes kind of
makes a nice little trail for them.
What I'll do is I'll make a trail
going to the front of where
I'm going to build a trap, and I'm making
a connecting trail to that game path
that I follow over there
The middle of winter
is the prime time to trap.
The reason is the fur is the thickest,
and that's the type of fur that I'm after.
It's a much better cubbie
than I thought it was going to be.
I got these six branches
to work in my favor.
Uhh the back of it is just kind of
naturally encased
in and close so the animal won't go
through the back and steal the bait.
It's going to come around to the easy
access, which will be the front.
This is the caribou stomach
from the last caribou I'd shot.
It's all frozen.
It's technically fresh.
This is the stuff that wolverines
and scavengers and fox like to eat.
So I'm going to offer them
this and I'm going
throw it all the way in the back there.
I've used leg hole traps in the past,
and they're not always
my favorite style of trap,
so these are body gripping traps
and these are the most humane traps
you can use and they're
my preferred trap to use, so
I just take this rope, put it
through the hole here, straight through,
pull here and what that does is
compress the springs.
So these are compressed these springs
and I got a little clip that holds them on
and that's kind of like the safety.
This is the trigger so if a wolverine
or a fox or something like that
came through, it's going to hit these
and the strap will close on it.
Any curious animal,
it's going to find itself inside the body
trap before reaching the bait.
There's no suffrage.
There's no pain.
Because these things are,
these things are dangerous, man.
I mean, this could easily break my arm.
So then you got to feel confident with
you got to feel comfortable with or
you’re gonna get yourself hurt.